こんにちは
はじめ）ってわけで皆さん実は最近はじめアミューズメントパークに
はじめ）乗り物来たの覚えてますでしょうかぃ？
やふへゐ）乗り物？　はじめ）乗り物
たなっち）乗り物？　はじめ）うん
はじめ）ま？
はじめ）車買ったじゃないっすか　たなっち）あぁ
はじめ）車買ったじゃないですか　車
やふへゐ）あは買いました　たなっち）確かに
はじめ）実はみんなで使う車を買ったんですけども
はじめ）まぁなんやかんや多分まだ綺麗なんすよ
たなっち）うんめっちゃ綺麗
はじめ）めっちゃ綺麗車が　やふへゐ）はい
はじめ）今日はなんとあの綺麗な車を
たなっち）うん
をしていこうと思います
【拍手】
はじめ）で流石にですねこればかりは多分
はじめ）一人だとカバーしきれないんで
たなっち）うん
はじめ）もう2人には仕掛け人になってもらって
はじめ）落書きされるのを前提に
はじめ）僕後発見するんでめっちゃくちゃ落書きされた車を
たなっち）はい
はじめ）2人にはもうそれを知っている前提でわざと怒ってほしい
はじめ）あの子ね
はじめ）って感じでそんだけです
やふへゐ・たなっち）わかりました
はい、というわけで仕込みはばっちりでございます
いやー車綺麗だからなぁやりたくないんですけど
こういうスプレーがありまして
スプラトゥーンみたい
うわー超ヤンキー使うやつじゃんこれ
もうゴリッゴリのスプレーなんですけども
これすごいところがですねー
布で拭き取ると取れるようになっております
だからもう一般的なイメージとして
なんかこうスプレーかけられたら落ちない感がすごいじゃないすか
それを買ったばっかりの車にバンバンやられると
流石のターゲットも車の変わり果てた姿を見て
怒る悲しむまたは、とち狂う
(だいち：ｳｱｧｱｱｧｱｱｱｧｧｧｱｱ)
何かしらのアクションがきっと起きると思うんですよ
大切なものが汚された瞬間の人の顔を見てみたいと思います
めっちゃ準備したんで早速やっていきましょう
では、いこう
はじめ）行くぜ
はじめ）はっはっはっ　地獄に落としてやるからな
はじめ）早速塗っていきます
カメラマン）あぁあぁあ…  はじめ）えっえっえ？
はじめ）待って？待って待ってｗ
カメラマン）はははｗｗ
はじめ）一回降りよｗｗ
カメラマン）ｗｗｗｗ
はじめ）一回降りよｗｗ待って
カメラマン）ｗｗｗｗｗ
(シュッ)
はじめ）びっくりした
はじめ）お、やば
はじめ）うわっ待って
はじめ）本当に大丈夫これ？
はじめ）本当に大丈夫？
カメラマン）え、落ちるんすかこれ
はじめ）やばい不安になってきちゃった
カメラマン）ｗｗｗ
はじめ）え、待って大丈夫かな
カメラマン）ふっｗははｗｗ
はじめ）理不尽ｗｗｗ
カメラマン）ふはははｗｗ
はじめ）はじめ！なんかイタズラっぽさを出したいんだよね
カメラマン）イタズラっぽさ
はじめ）どうでしょう　はじめ！キエろ
(だいち：ﾌﾟｱｧｧ)
はじめ）こんなもんだっしょっかな　どうでしょう
はじめ）ごめんなさいごめんなさい
はい、というわけで完成しましたいかがでしょうか
もうなんか、こういうの見たことあるんすけど
なんか本当にバカな人が書いたような
スプレーのイタズラっぽくしたんで
割とリアリティは出てるのではないかなと思います
で、こっからターゲットを誘って車に乗せるんで
リアクションをお楽しみください
たなっち）大家さんが
たなっち）なんかあったんすか
はじめ）大家さん？
はじめ）車？
だいち）なんか車動かしてって言われた
だいち）なんかあのお手伝いじゃない？
はじめ）あぁ
だいち心の声）テメェいつかぶっ殺してやるからな
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】